aquí les reto a la tortuga a una carrera
de 10 km sintiéndose bastante confiado
en su rapidez aquí les dio a la tortuga
dos horas de ventaja para después correr
lo más rápido que pudo a una velocidad
constante cuál de las siguientes
gráficas describe la relación entre la
posible velocidad a la cual aquiles
corrió en kilómetros por hora y la
duración de su carrera a esa velocidad
en horas incluyendo las dos horas de
ventaja para empezar te invito a que le
des pausa al vídeo y trates de
determinar cuál de estas gráficas
describe la relación entre la posible
velocidad a la cual aquiles corrió en
kilómetros por hora es este eje que
tenemos aquí y la duración de la carrera
cuánto tiempo le tomo incluyendo las dos
horas de ventaja para poder analizar
estas gráficas empecemos recordando que
distancia es igual a velocidad por
tiempo o podemos decir que es igual a la
tasa de cambio por duración en todas las
gráficas tenemos duración como la
variable dependiente y la velocidad
de cambio como la variable independiente
y sabemos que es una carrera de 10 km
así es que podemos escribir esto como
tiempo es igual a distancia sobre
velocidad
lo que equivale a qué tiempo es igual a
distancia que son 10 kilómetros sobre la
velocidad sobre la velocidad ahora
podemos hacer una pequeña tabla en la
cual le demos distintos valores a la
velocidad para ver cuáles serían los
valores correspondientes al tiempo muy
bien veamos eso aquí voy a tener la
columna con la velocidad aunque no hay
mucho espacio aquí si me da para poner
23 valores y acá voy a poner la columna
con el tiempo con la duración de la
carrera
elegimos entonces un valor para la
velocidad vemos que la velocidad va de 2
hasta 18 empecemos con una velocidad de
2 kilómetros por hora vamos a calcular a
2 kilómetros por hora
cuál sería la duración de la carrera de
aquiles entonces el tiempo es la
distancia que son 10 kilómetros dividido
entre la velocidad que son 2 kilómetros
por hora muy bien ahora
recordemos que las unidades las podemos
tratar como números no son exactamente
números pero eso es lo maravilloso del
análisis dimensional entonces para hacer
este cálculo voy a multiplicar 10
kilómetros por el recíproco de 2
kilómetros por hora entonces tenemos 10
kilómetros o el recíproco de 2 que es un
medio por el recíproco de kilómetros por
hora que es ahora por kilómetros y esto
hace sentido porque si tenemos
kilómetros sobre kilómetros por hora
bueno no me voy a meter en eso lo
interesante aquí es que estos kilómetros
se cancelan con estos kilómetros y
tenemos ahora que son las unidades en
las cuales esperamos obtener el tiempo y
aquí tenemos entonces que el tiempo va a
ser 10 por un medio son 5 horas vamos a
borrar esto al fin ya hicimos el cálculo
y no queremos amontonarnos aquí
así es que borró esto y escribimos el
resultado de que la duración de la
carrera de aquiles cuando su velocidad
es 2 kilómetros por hora es de 5 horas
veamos ahora cuál de estas gráficas es
consistente con este punto que acabamos
de obtener
espera aquí no hemos incluido las dos
horas que le da aquí les de ventaja a la
tortuga así es que esta duración tendría
que ser 52 más dos horas tenemos que
incluir estas dos horas que le da de
ventaja kill es más dos horas es igual a
siete horas para que quede claro lo que
acabo de hacer / 10 / 2 para obtener que
la duración de la carrera de aquiles era
5 horas pero a eso tenemos que sumarle
las 2 horas de ventaja que le dio a la
tortuga así es que tenemos 7 horas
veamos cuál de estas gráficas es
consistente con eso 2 kilómetros por
hora 7 horas aquí estaría pero vemos que
ese punto no está incluido en la gráfica
si es que esta gráfica no corresponde 2
kilómetros por hora 7 horas este punto
si se encuentra sobre la gráfica 2
kilómetros por hora 7 horas aquí no está
sobre la gráfica 2 kilómetros por hora y
7 horas tampoco está sobre esta gráfica
así es que prácticamente con un único
punto hemos determinado que la gráfica 2
es la que corresponde ahora otra manera
resolver esto sin necesidad de encontrar
el valor de un punto es considerar que
si yo voy rápido si yo corro rápido hago
menos tiempo
mientras que si voy lento si voy lento
hago más tiempo eso es mínimo sentido
común y así en esta gráfica cuando voy
lento hago más tiempo y cuando voy
rápido algo menos tiempo está hace
sentido en esta de aquí cuando voy lento
hago más tiempo y cuando voy rápido algo
menos tiempo inclusive hay un tiempo
límite que son dos horas las dos horas
que le dan aquí les de ventaja la
tortuga así es que está hace sentido
también en la siguiente rápida gráfica
tenemos que si voy lento algo menos
tiempo pero si voy rápido también hago
más tiempo así es que esta gráfica no
hace ningún sentido y en la gráfica 4 si
voy lento hago menos tiempo mientras que
si voy rápido hago más tiempo esta
tampoco hace sentido así es que con esta
lógica eliminaría estas dos gráficas así
es que ahora haciendo la comparación de
estas dos gráficas esta primera gráfica
es claramente una función lineal con
pendiente negativa mientras que la
gráfica 2 definitivamente no es una
función lineal esto se ve claramente
aquí en la
fórmula de la función donde r es la
variable independiente vemos que
claramente esto no es una función lineal
aquí no es 10 kilómetros por ere's 10
kilómetros dividido entre r para que
fuera una función lineal como esta que
tenemos aquí tendría que ser de la forma
t igual a un número n que multiplica la
velocidad más otro número b donde está m
que es la pendiente es un número
negativo no hay manera que puede
escribir esto de la forma que tenemos
aquí de la forma t igual a un número x
número dividido entre b así es que de
esa manera podemos descartar la gráfica
1 claramente esto no es lineal no se
puede escribir de esta forma así es que
hemos eliminado la gráfica 1 y
significamos esta función vamos a
obtener esta forma que no es lineal te
sugiero que gráfica es esta función
tomando varios puntos para que te
convenzas como puedes ver hay muchas
maneras de hacer esto y te invito a que
busques por tu cuenta otras maneras pero
definitivamente está que tenemos aquí la
gráfica 2 es la que describe la relación
entre la posible velocidad la cual
aquiles corrió
y la duración de su carrera incluyendo
las 2 horas de ventaja si incluyéramos
esas dos horas de ventaja esta gráfica
la tendríamos que mover hacia abajo en
dos unidades al moverla hacia abajo en
dos unidades la gráfica se vería más o
menos así más o menos así estoy moviendo
todo hacia abajo dos unidades dos
unidades pero esta incluye las dos horas
de ventaja es por eso que esta gráfica
nunca nunca va a ir abajo de dos horas
aunque aquí les alcance la velocidad de
la luz